you scare me even like when i was
watching the movie and i love that eric
andre does a guest appearance at machine
gun he does a guest appearance it's
great but i wouldn't go anywhere near
your set when eric andre goes up to buy
something at the little cart there and
they and he gets smacked with that
[ __ ] thing or machine gun kelly he's
riding a bike and he gets smacked in the
head and thrown into the water i mean
that [ __ ] really hurts that's no joke
they got the full treatment uh you would
be you would be safe on our set and i i
i guarantee that um there are people
that we go after
and
we wouldn't go after you
because i i even asked tremaine
the director of jackass who'd worked
with eric andre
and shauna newton who had worked with
eric andre on bad trip i'm like does he
get the full treatment or what and
they're like kill him i'm like okay
you don't have to beg me well
they're friends with eric and they know
that he wants the full treatment and uh
so we have discussions ahead of time how
we're going to treat people well the
funny story i heard about you was uh
you've developed this friendship with
eric andre and he got covered and on
christmas eve you wanted to cheer him up
so you toilet papered his entire house
and eric didn't know it was you and then
he he took out a gun and almost shot you
yeah
and then you said to him you weren't
upset about it you said oh this if you
shoot me that would be good promotion
for jackass forever like oh he was a
businessman
i was toilet paper in his house and uh
he kept yelling out to he kept yelling
out the door i've called the cops i've
called the cops i have a gun i have a
gun and i'm just i'm doubled over right
and then i go up to his door
and i put my face against this glass
door and he's screaming at me and he
walks up and he sees me he's like oh you
[ __ ]
and he goes the cops are coming right
now i'm like don't tell them that it's
me just let them come arrest me it'll be
great
and he goes i could have shot you you
know i'm like that would have been even
better yeah
there's no fear factor did you approach
anybody who said [ __ ] you johnny i am
not gonna do a cameo in your uh movie
because i'm scared shitless of this
i
don't believe there were
um because
we usually reach out to people we have a
relationship with
so everyone agreed there's a cameo that
we wanted to work in the movie but by
the time we heard about it was too late
bruce dern had contacted
uh someone and they're like brewster and
wants to be in jackass and we're like
that i we would love bruce stern to be
in jackass but now he's kind of done
filming
isn't bruce stern like he's got to be in
his 80s now right i've been bruised
because he'd be great you know
he'd been peanut gallery he'd been
peanut gallery on something you know